-You know, it's not often that
there's good news these days
but an exciting thing
happened this week
right here in New York.
A local meteorologist is at home
and recovering from surger
after a viewer pointed out
a spot on her neck
which turned out
to be cancerous melanoma.
Here to talk about it
is the meteorologist
from KPRN New York,
Jennifer Hollingsworth
and the eagle-eyed viewer
from Long Island City,
Malcolm Briggs.
Thank you both so much
for being here.
-It's so good to be here, Seth
-So, Jennifer, this is
a fascinating story,
but before we get into it,
how are you feeling?
-Oh, well, I'm feeling great
Seth.
I got out of surgery yesterday
very minor,
and the doctor said
my melanoma is totally treated
-That is wonderful.
And, Malcolm, you were watchin
TV, and you noticed the mole
-That's right, Seth.
I was watching television,
and I saw an abnormality,
and I wrote her a direct message
on Twitter to let her know
-Incredible.
So, Jennifer, had you seen
the mole before?
-Honestly, no, Seth.
It was a really small mole
It was the size of a pin.
Like, it was barely a freckle.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah. None of my coworker
and none of my family member
saw it.
Like, no one noticed it.
That's how tiny this thing was
-So, Malcolm, how'd you manage
to see something that small?
-Well, yeah, you know,
I have no idea, Seth.
I just saw it, I guess.
-Huh.
-What?
-I mean, it's just, uh,
you just happened to notic
this microscopic spot
on her neck?
I mean, just seems
like you must have been
looking really close
at her skin, huh?
-Oh, I don't know if I was
looking really close exactly
-Right, but I mean,
you must have been
staring at me pretty hard,
right?
It's okay. You can admit it.
Did you record it and watch it
a bunch of times or something?
-[ Chuckles ] What? No! What
Why would I d--
Why would I do that?
-I don't know, Malcolm.
Why would you do that?
-Wait, uh, I'm sorry.
You guys --
What are you guys implying here?
Like...
-Nothing.
Nothing.
But I mean,
you got to admit it is...
kinda weird, right?
-Weird? I -- [ Chuckles ]
I don't think it's weird.
-Yeah.
I mean, you're not a doctor,
so how'd you notice
a small spot on my skin?
Did you, like, memorize my skin?
-[ Chuckles ] No!
[ Stammers ]
No. Well, you know,
a -- a friend of mine
had a similar skin cancer
a few years ago.
-Okay. Sure.
-Yeah, and I -- and I thin
anyone in my situation
would've done the same thing
-Well, to be fair, I think mos
people look at the forecast.
They're not ogling
the meteorologist.
-Ogling? No.
I -- I saved your life.
-Um, I'm pretty sure
the doctor saved my life.
-No, no, of course the doc--
But I just -- I mean, look
Listen, I'm not
some kind of creep.
-Whoa! No one thinks your
a creep, Malcolm. Take it easy
-Someone's a little sensitive.
-Look, we can just move on
It's fine.
-Okay. I...
-So, um, Malcolm,
you noticed the abnormalit
on her neck,
and then you decided
to tweet at her.
-That's right.
-You just sent her a tweet
-Yep.
-You decided to use
the opportunity to
slide into her DMs.
-Seth!
-You're right. You're right.
I'm sorry.
-Look, this is ridiculous.
I was watching TV and I happened
to notice a small mole
that turned out to be cancerous,
and I did what anyone would,
okay?
I tweeted at her,
and I turned out to be right
[ Scoffs ]
You -- Okay, you still
don't believe me, do you?
-No.
-Not really.
-Okay, well, you know what
My wife is right here, and
she'll explain what happened
Honey? Honey, could you
come in here for a minute?
-Yeah, what is it?
-Okay, honey. Alright.
You remember when I spotte
the meteorologist's mole, right?
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And I pointed out the mol
and I said it looked cancerous
You saw the mole too, right?
-You know,
I didn't see it at first,
but when you pointed it out,
I got really close to the screen
and I guess I could see
what you were talking about.
-Okay. Great. Thanks, honey.
See? [ Chuckles ]
That mole wasn't that small.
Anyone could see it.
-Uh-huh. Hey, by the way,
why didn't you tell your wif
to wipe off all
the powdered sugar on her face
before appearing
on national television?
-Powdered sugar?
What powdered sugar?
-Yeah, there was, like, powdered
sugar all over her face.
-Oh, my God.
I was ogling the meteorologist
-Thank you!
-Oh, my God. I'm so sorry.